und wir schauen weiter auf die
besonderen momente in diesem krieg die
uns bewegt haben die besonderen menschen
die wir kennen gelernt haben und auf ja
so manche wahrheit vermeintliche die wir
neu lernen müssen so manche propaganda
klischees peter tiede bei mir im studio
noch die im moment über den haufen
geworfen werden zum einen das klischee
von der großen starken russischen armee
die gerade vor den augen der welt ihre
schwächen offenbart zum anderen gibt es
auch diesen tschetschenischen kämpfer
von kadyrow auf dem statthalter putins
dort in tschetschenien und die haben
sich und da wollen wir mal reinschauen
in ihren propagandavideos ebenfalls
selbst entlarvt er
gilt als putins bluthund der mann fürs
grobe
tschetscheniens machthaber ramsan
kadyrov
kurz nach kriegsbeginn gibt
tschetschenen chef kadyrov bekannt dass
er seinen todestrieb zur unterstützung
des russischen militärs in die ukraine
schickt die k die rossi
eine 80.000 mann starke einheit aus
tschetschenien putin skrupelloses
killerkommando eine kampferprobte horde
ohne gewissen sie kommen um zu morden
jetzt der verdacht wird hier nur verbal
scharf geschossen das ganze nur eine
propagandalüge die furchtlosen kämpfer
nur in social media bild spricht mit dem
russischen militärexperten russland
level chef der gruppe konflikt
intelligence er analysiert exklusiv für
bild das vorgehen der kategorie in
putins blutigem angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine
seit ich den ersten tagen sind sie in
der ukraine
allerdings haben wir seit beginn der
operation keine schlacht gesehen an der
degradierung soldaten teilgenommen habe
seit den ersten tagen befinden sie sich
im hinterland nehmen videos auf und
versuchen sie lenski ukrainischen
soldaten oder nationalisten ist es
drohen einmal haben sie selbst etwas als
schlacht bezeichnet das war bei einer
militärbasis der ukrainische
nationalgarde in hostel bei kiew aber es
ist bekannt dass die militärbasis mehr
war sie sind auf eine leere basis
gekommen haben mit niemandem bekämpft
eine tschetschenische flagge gehisst und
behauptet dass sie krasse kämpfer wären
rund eine basis eingenommen
auch die unzähligen mobilisierungs
videos in den sozialen netzwerken sind
seiner meinung nach nichts weiter als
heiße luft
nachdem nach einigen tagen klar wurde
dass die kadyrov soldaten nicht kämpfen
und als soldaten völlig nutzlos sind
haben sie den br druck erhöht sie haben
also noch mehr videos gedreht auf denen
sie irgendwas beschießen aber es ist nie
klar wohin sie schießen und offen wen
sie schießen man sieht nie einen gegner
unterlegen sie werden auf keinen video
das ramzan kadyrov selbst gepostet hat
ein feind sehen in einem der
bekanntesten videos beschießen sie ein
haus mario pohl am ende des videos
halten sie ein abzeichen des soft
bataillon see um kamera offenbar war der
ganze gegner ist abzeichnet angeblich
sollen nationalisten in dem hochhaus
gewesen sein aber sie zeigen wir leder
die waffen der angeblichen nationalisten
noch ihre leicht für uns ist klar sie
nehmen auch weiter hinten nicht an den
kämpfen teil sie werden weiterhin
geschont sie versuchen weiterhin den
eindruck zu erwecken dass ihr trasse
soldaten seien obwohl das nicht so ist
selbst in ihren eigenen videos in denen
sich schießend man klar dass sie
keinerlei kampf erfahren sie begehen
größte fehler bei den fragen wer hinter
wem steht und wer wie entdeckt
alles deutet daraufhin dass die
kämpfende truppe völlig nutzlos ist sie
haben keine entsprechende ausbildung
oder vorbereitet sie können keinen krieg
führen das einzige was sie tun können
ist gefangene zu foltern menschen zu
entführen und unbewaffnete zu töten auch
der britische guardian vermutet dass
putins pitbulls bereits zu beginn des
krieges verlustreich gekämpft haben der
enthusiasmus soll immer mehr schwinden
mittlerweile sollen die kämpfer mehr mit
ihren social media accounts beschäftigt
sein als mit der von russland
vorgeschobenen befreiung der ukraine
fakt ist die daten ihrer mobiltelefone
zeigen dass sich die meisten aus putins
stoßtrupp gar nicht mehr im kampf
befinden sondern 20 kilometer weiter
hinter der front
[Musik]
also peter der vermeintliche todestrieb
nur enttäuschung in einem großen teilen
ja der verdacht ist nicht neu als ich
selbst im grenzgebiet waren zwar
belgorod das ist quasi nördlich von
cardiff wo die wie sein sollten auch da
waren die im hotel und nicht draußen da
waren es gibt so ein großes hotel mitten
in der stadt ein altes sozialistisches
ist ganz gut sagt sieht man eine menge
aber
kriegsgebiet ist eine ecke weg und da
waren die in der regel um sie dann weg
fahren sie mal als sie ankommt kommen
sehen aber so richtig abgekämpft haben
sie denn tatsächlich nicht aus ich lass
uns mal darüber sprechen vor dieser
großen gefahren von man dachte dass wir
stehen würden und im moment sieht die
situation ein bisschen anders aus es
gibt ukrainische gewinne dorte um kiew
herum die russische armee wirkt im
moment nicht sehr bedrohlich ich kann
mich erinnern du warst eine kurz bevor
der krieg
ausbrach was du in rostov am don dort
unten und du warst der erste der eine
riesige wagen kolonne von
militärfahrzeugen gefilmt hat die bilder
gingen damals um die welt war wir
wussten jetzt steht der krieg
tatsächlich unmittelbar bevor das war
damals die angst war groß ist halt
mächtig aus endlos diese wagenkolonne
und jetzt stehen die russen plötzlich da
so werden sie jedenfalls dargestellt als
sozusagen die trottel von der kompanie
wo liegt die wahrheit die wahrheit liegt
dazwischen aber eher bei den trotteln da
kommt man die so blutig und so
fürchterlich das alles für die ukrainer
ist für die russische armee und für die
russische propaganda für die russischen
präsidenten ist das ein fiasko richtiges
motto warum das was ich damals gefilmt
habe das waren mehr als 400 fahrzeuge
dann in summe die gehörten zu den
modernsten was man hat das war ein
spielplatz trocken also spezialtruppen
die waren speziell ausgebildet die haben
spezielle fahrzeuge die sind moderne
ausgelost der ganze rest der russischen
armee unterliegt einer enormen
korruption an jeder stelle wo
investitionen stattfinden sollen wird
einfach mal so ein drittel bis die
hälfte des geldes einfach geklaut und
dann hat man dann am ende des tages
fahrzeuge die auf billigen chinesischen
reifen fahren die die traglast nicht
haben für die lkws und für die technik
die da transportiert werden müssen dann
ich bin selber aufgewachsen an
westlichsten truppenübungsplatz der
warschauer vertragsstaaten da in der
nähe von die grenze zwischen brandenburg
zwischen mecklenburg halbe strecke
berlin-hamburg und da hat man gesehen
früher schon wie die armee ausgerüstet
ist und was da ist es bleibt immer ein
drittel irgendwo liegen oder geht kaputt
und wenn man das ist zum teil auch bei
auch bei den militärfahrzeugen das ist
zum teil einfache technik ist einfach zu
reparieren das heißt aber auch du
brauchst immer drei fahrzeuge um ein
fahrtüchtiges zu haben nach einer
bestimmten anzahl von wochen und von
kampfeinsätzen hinzu kommt das wetter
man hat damit gerechnet dass zu dieser
jahreszeit ist üblicherweise noch
tiefgefroren ist im donbass und dann
kannst du mit der fahrzeugkolonne hat
der breite nachfahren 50 panzer
nebeneinander einer wird geschossen von
49 weiter 50 panzer hintereinander einer
wird beschossen und zwar der erste 50
panzer stehen es hier hat keiner mehr
weil er rechts und links nicht runter
kann weil sie einfach in matsch
versinken dazu kommt dass die ukraine
hervor und ausgebildet sind die ukraine
haben auf eine partie sahen technik
gesetzt die hatten zum teil die calanda
zu das ist ein geologischer generali
ehemals georgischer general in
kriegszeiten georgisch hat jahr 2014 an
der befreiung mario puls beteiligt waren
mit ausgearbeitet da hat man darauf
gesetzt dass man die russen kommunisten
ist auch die kolonnen reinfallen ist und
den nachschub abschneiden ist eine
klassische partisan taktik deswegen
sehen wir zum beispiel russische
russische panzer fahrzeuge und auch lkw
konvois nicht viel tiefer als 140 200
kilometer ins landesinnere fahren weil
er bei der nachschub nicht in ort also
korruption schlechtes material ganz ganz
viel bluff schlechte verpflegung
schlechte moral auch also die leute
kommen lassen sowie die soldaten man das
wirklich interessieren also offenbar
generalstabsmäßig nicht gut geplant das
ganze aber wie ticken die soldaten was
sind das überhaupt für leute sind die
top vorbereitet sind das elite truppen
oder sind das leute die von irgendwoher
weit entfernt aus dem ganzen team
gekauft werden da sind mix aus einem
jetzt wird wahrscheinlich die zweite
welle gestartet werden jetzt kommen
wirklich berufssoldaten aus allen teilen
des landes zum anfang waren sehr viele
junge soldaten dabei zum teil auch
wirklich wehrdienstleistende und die
kommt zum teil auch aus dem aus dem
fernen osten also aus dem fernen osten
haben ja gesehen sind ganz viele truppen
hin verlegt worden unter den ist ja
erzielt worden also die inter mit einem
hurra enthusiasmus eingegangen weil sie
die ihr gegen die nazis kämpfen und weil
die ukrainer ja sich ergeben werden und
sie feiern werden und dann stehen die
zivilisten auf der straße keine keine
nazis dann stehen großmutter frauen
männer kinder auf der straße stoppen
ihre konvois keiner gibt ihnen blumen
jeder gibt ihm zu verstehen haut ab dann
wird dann kommen noch bauern mit einem
traktor und klauen die noch die panzer
dazu dann noch die vielen verluste da
sind sie ganz schnell demoralisiert und
dann wenn dann tatsächlich auch der
drill der und der ton der innerhalb
dieser truppe herrscht er ist derartig
brutal und es ist streng hierarchisch
natürlich wie immer so aber die
russische armee ist tatsächlich noch aus
sowjetzeiten eine nach innen brutal
geführte armee und dann sind die
soldaten auch noch ganz ganz schlecht
verfliegt und wenn das alles
zusammenkommt bricht das auch die moral
kommt so an der skurrilsten momente auch
das hat damit zu tun dass die russen
offenbar überrascht sind wie gut die
ukraine inzwischen ausgerüstet sind wir
haben lange über die waffenlieferungen
gesprochen auch aus deutschland die
nicht man wusste nicht sind die jetzt
schon da wo sind die überhaupt oder
sonstwas und unser reporter paul
ronzheimer der aus kiew berichtet die
ganze zeit schon hat dann tatsächlich
exklusiv so ein waffenlager sehen können
und da in der tat spielte sich ein sehr
skurriler moment umsatz paul ronzheimer
musste lachen
das hier ist eine deutsche kanzler
abwehrwaffe wir sehen hier achtung vor
dem verschluss ist der kopfschutz von
der patrone zu entfernen hier sehen wir
die deutsche schrift auf dieser panzer
abwehr wache und die sind hier
angekommen in diesem lager
nicht wie uns juli sagt juri ist dieser
german way you are
also mediapad und wie sie nutzen youtube
um zu verstehen wie mit dieser panzer
abwehrwaffe tatsächlich operiert werden
kann also youtube ist der instructor für
die deutschen warten schon sehr skurril
sie haben 40 von diesen deutschen
panzerabwehrwaffen hier mit ihr
verhalten aber sie haben bereits 20
verschoss und 20 benutzt thomas und die
medien gerne dadurch chance
als er zeigt uns jetzt einmal hier diese
solche panzer erwartet
es ist so einfach ist es ist so einfach
wie ein deutscher volkswagen hatte hier
also mitten in einem waffenlager in
tschuldigung wenn ich hier auch mal
lachen in diesen stunden aber das ist
schon sehr skurril also mit youtube
funktioniert hier die anleitung für
diese deutsche panzerabwehrwaffen und
julia es ist so einfach wie ein
deutscher volkswagen und wir brauchen
mehr davon juni
politisches verfahren handle
er sagt er muss es verstehen und wir
werden ihnen das zeigen wir werden das
lehrerin also hier erneut die
klaren worte von ukrainischen soldaten
mit im bild die deutsche panzerfaust
noch einmal der sagt wir werden klagen
putin das schon zeigen die wahrheit über
diesen krieg also man sieht der
widerstand in der ukraine ist
ungebrochen und ich nehme euch hier
vielleicht einmal noch mal ganz kurz mit
denn so oft kommt man nicht hier in so
einen wachen lager wie das aussieht und
wie die leute hier auch arbeiten
juli steht dort bei den deutschen
panzerabwehrwaffen aber wir sehen hier
natürlich wie auch dinge repariert
werden buch geführt wird hier wir sehen
dort im hintergrund ein paar vertonen
wir sind dort waffen und wir sehen auch
hier hinter frische waffen die
angekommen sind in diesem moment
und in diese richtung
ebenfalls patron und dann gehen wir noch
einmal zurück juli wir keine chance
das ist eine sowjetische sache in diesem
fall
also er sagt die sowjetische sache sehr
viel schwieriger zu betrieben als die
deutsche waffe und soldaten die
erfahrung haben die zum beispiel im
krieg seit 2014 schon gekämpft haben die
wissen dann auch sofort wie man diese
deutsche waffe bedient so
augsburg der parlamente bino der - und
hier in uk
also wenn es keine anti flugverbots wenn
es keine flugverbotszone gibt dann
werden wir unser land anders verteidigen
dann werden wir auch so uns helfen
können aber ich wollte jetzt noch mal
nach ob es dringend sozusagen aus dem
klinischen sichtbar benötigt wird sowohl
als to you need for germany so
rasch als
er sagt wenn ihr schon nicht eine
flugverbotszone wohl wenn ich schon
nicht den himmel schließen können wo es
dann gibt uns mehr mit dem wir sozusagen
auf flugzeuge auf raketen feuern können
50 kilometer von hier versuchen die
russisch haben wir gerade mit
helikoptern sagt der 50 kilometer von
hier weitere soldaten reinzubringen und
wenn es etwas gäbe mit dem sie sozusagen
auf diese helikopter feuern könnten dann
würde das der ukrainischen armee sehr
helfen
[Musik]
der katholische
klinik ihre positionen irgendwohin
wir werden definitiv gewinnen da gibt es
keine chance so zusagen für eine
niederlage sie sind bereit für einen
langen krieg und sie werden diesen krieg
gewinnen sagt julie hier live in diesem
moment aus einem waffenlager mitten in
hier
also in youtube erklärt filmchen lernen
die ukraine wie man eine deutsche
panzerfaust den volkswagen unter den
waffen beliefern das ist klingt wie ein
witz als würde man eine satire film über
einen krieg machen ja aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass die ukrainer kinder
der sowjetunion sind auch mit ihrer
armee und auch mit ausrüstung auch mit
der technik und jetzt also man kommt
quasi von kalaschnikow und bekommt jetzt
andere sachen andere waffensysteme und
die muss man tatsächlich erst erlernen
sie sind auch nicht kritisch beschriftet
und skurril war auch der satz von juri
dem waffenmeister dort der gesagt hat ja
die deutschen denken bei den waffen
immer an die menschen also er meint
natürlich die die bedienen so traurig
wie das ist und so dramatisch wie das
alles ist aber solche momente zeigen
einfach auch das dann einfache dinge
funktionieren das ist manchmal einfach
auch shrek läuft es zeigt aber auch die
ganze absurdität wenn man vom universum
aus drauf schaut sozusagen nie wieder
krieg nach dem zweiten weltkrieg das war
völlig klar generationen sind damit groß
geworden und jetzt sehen wir situationen
wie im zweiten weltkrieg zum ersten mal
seitdem wird wieder ein land mit einer
riesigen streit machte überfallen und
gleichzeitig sitzen die leute dann
darunter youtube
tutorials um zu lernen wie man waffen
bedienen kann aber das zeigt halt auch
das wirklich friedenszeiten herrscht und
dass man darauf auch nicht vorbereitet
war dass niemand daran gedacht hat dass
es so einen wladimir putin noch einmal
geben kann in europa in unserem
zeitalter der schlicht und ergreifend im
wortsinn alle grenzen überschreitet und
das dann in verschiedenen sprachen mit
verschiedenen waffen system gearbeitet
werden muss zeigt auf der anderen seite
auch dass man da zusammen steht gegen
diesen mann und das hilfe ankommt man
kann ganz wie man kann ganz viel
kritisieren auch daran wie der
deutschland agiert aber fest steht die
hilfe ist da sie mag nicht genug sein
aber sie kommt und auch deutschland ist
zumindest etwas über seinen schatten
gesprungen und wenn sie jetzt den
volkswagen unter dem panzerabwehrwaffen
haben dann
der ukrainische - aber wie sinnlos
dieser krieg ist zeigt sehr symbolhafte
geschichte eines mannes boris romanenko
ein 96 jähriger mann der den zweiten
weltkrieg erlebt hat der vier
konzentrationslager überlebt hat der
letztlich von der roten armee befreit
wurde die die konzentrationslager
befreit hat und der jetzt von russland
beschlossen wurde bombardiert wurde und
mit 96 jahren gestorben ist
er ging durch die hölle und kam wieder
heraus buchenwald peenemünde
mittelbau-dora
bergen belsen
konzentrationslager die zu grabstätten
von zu vielen menschen wurden nicht aber
von ihm hier boris um eine schenkung
geboren am 20 januar 1926 bei sony in
der heutigen ukraine
zweiter weltkrieg hitler überfällt die
sowjetunion und boris wird 1942 als
16-jähriger von deutschen streitkräften
ins deutsche reich verschleppt und
zwangsarbeit zu leisten
nach einem fluchtversuch wird er ins
konzentrationslager buchenwald
deportiert
dann geht es nach peenemünde wo er
gezwungen wird an der v2 rakete zu
arbeiten weitere stationen seiner
inhaftierung waren das kz mittelbau-dora
und das kz bergen belsen
er überlebte die hölle der 40er jahre
zeitsprung eine neue halle dieser fiel
boris im alter von 96 jahren nun zum
opfer hier in seinen eigenen vier wänden
in seiner wohnung in kharkiv starb bures
am 18 märz das gebäude wurde von einer
russischen bombe getroffen wo man
schenke starb seine wohnung brannte aus
er war 96 jahre alt bitte denken sie
daran was er alles durchgemacht hat er
überlebte buchenwald dora mittelbau
peenemünde und bergen belsen die von
hitler geschaffenen todes bahn
mit jedem tag dieses krieges wird
deutlich was entnazifizierung für die
russen bedeutet
[Musik]
hitlers holocaust überlebt gut ins
sogenannte
entnazifizierung nicht die sinnlosigkeit
seines todes und dieses krieges wird
immer deutlicher
und während hier seine vermeintlichen
überreste geborgen werden boris
romanenko jetzt durch keine hölle mehr
gehen muss tun dies nun millionen
ukraine weiterhin jeden tag aufs neue
[Musik]
ja ein
sinnloser krieg und wir wissen nicht wie
lange er noch anhalten wird aber peter
irgendwann wird es eine zeit danach
gegeben und wir müssen uns fragen was
passiert dann putin jetzt weltweit
geächtet sanktionen werden mit
sanktionen wird das land belegt die
russen leiden auch darunter was passiert
danach werden die dann einfach wieder
weggenommen die supermärkte sind wieder
voll man kann wieder zu mcdonald's gehen
oder wird russland zu einem riesigen
nordkorea werden sozusagen und was
bedeutet das dann auch für uns alle das
hängt davon ab wer nach diesem krieg
dieses land führt und welche wege und in
welche richtung eins steht fest
deutschland ist damals befreit worden
von den alliierten russland wird nicht
befreit werden von westlichen mächten
russland muss selbst mit sich klar
kommen das hängt dann davon ab wer für
dieses land und in welche richtung der
wahrscheinlichste weg ist dass man zum
anhänger oder zum anhängsel von peking
wird und dass man tatsächlich gucken
muss wie man miteinander wie man klar
kommt fest steht der westen wird die
ukraine aufbauen nicht russland befreien
und nicht russland helfen das darf man
auch nicht russland muss wenn es soweit
ist diesen weg weiter gehen will dann
muss russland diesen weg alleine weiter
gehen ohne uns die ukraine muss von uns
aufgebaut werden das wird auch werden
hat die europäische union hat einen
dieser woche beschlossen dass man ein
wiederaufbauprogramm macht und dann
werden die leute im don was und auf der
krim falls diese gebiete verloren
bleiben sollten dann werden die 20
jahren an den zaun gehen können können
sich löcher rein bohren kann sich kisten
hinstellen können darüber gucken rein
riechen schmecken und werden sehen dass
der westen ein blüht eine blühende
ukraine aufgebaut hat die wahrscheinlich
hoffentlich demokratisch ist die
entsolidarisierung ist und die frei ist
und dann können die in don was
meinetwegen den kitt aus den fenstern
fressen aber sie werden von uns wenn
sich der weg nicht ändert wenn russland
keine andere führung hat keinen anderen
weg einschlägt dann werden sie alleine
bleiben ohne uns die ukraine aber mit
uns twitter danke dass du hier bei mir
war es im studio und dass wir zusammen
auf ja besondere menschen und momente
schauen können seit über vier wochen
seit über einem monat krieg in der
ukraine
ich danke ihnen meine damen und herren
für ihre aufmerksamkeit